the court Juanita Fillion preserving our
own culture here in Berlin is only
possible when we speak our own language
when we cook and eat our traditional
dishes and share our culture with other
people under the norm eaten wonderful -
uh yeah spending time together as a
family is also very important it's a big
aspect of our culture their plate
Melanie and unhone eight kovash are
sisters they were born in San Pablo in
the Philippines their mother a nurse by
profession came to Germany in 1986 she
married a German man and five years
later brought her daughters here when
they were nine and ten years old okay
and I mr. Honda's man and what a time
effect I remember when my mother left
but we have a big family in the
Philippines with many cousins it's not
unusual there for children to grow up
with their grandmothers there Lola which
means grandmother in our language our
grandmother's raised us in place of our
parents and mothers I can remember that
I had a very happy childhood my
grandmother and my aunts were all there
and they helped fill that gap after high
school Melanie and Antoinette kovash
both trained as hotel managers in
Britain their goal was to start their
own business together in 2011 they
opened a pun the first restaurant of its
kind in the city the same original it's
a blend of Asian and Spanish cuisine the
Philippines were long under Spanish
colonial rule and we adopted many things
from them the language cuisine a bit of
their culture that's what makes our
cuisine rather special it's not overly
seasoned with various herbs and it's not
as spicy as Thai food it's not as
heavily seasoned with herbs as
Vietnamese cuisine it's more in the
middle beef tapa is a traditional dish
in the Philippines
on this Southeast Asian archipelago
hearty and savory dishes are popular at
every time of the day traditionally
there are six meals a day
all of them cooked the marinade is part
of what makes beef tapa special the
marinades dark color comes from soy
sauce and annatto powder the spice is
relatively unknown in Europe but it's
available in Asian supermarkets
for the best flavor the beef should
marinate for at least an hour
rice is served with nearly every meal in
the Philippines beef tapa is served with
grilled vegetables and fragrant rice
it's the best seller at pan restaurant
in a keynote Congress's often ate this a
lot as children especially at breakfast
where we often eat hearty meals we have
rice for breakfast lunch and dinner and
something hearty along with it breakfast
is the most important meal in the
Philippines that's why our menu includes
beef tapa as an Asian breakfast as a
dishes for stirred the beef tapa the
cover sisters aren't just creative in
the kitchen they also help design the
interior of their restaurant when they
took over the lease they renovated the
rooms from the ground up in just three
weeks
[Music]
these paintings are uncle net covetous
work the numbers on the wall are geodata
which identify locations like San Pablo
where the sisters were born and Manila
the capital of the Philippines the
restaurant in the Prenzlauer Berg
district of northeastern Berlin draws a
diverse and cosmopolitan crowd pun is a
favorite with families and locals who
enjoy sampling new flavors
although pun also draws inspiration from
other Asian cuisines traditional
Philippine recipes are the mainstay of
the menu
[Music]
hello paul mcguigan kabayan and the loot
on papyrus anyway on a beef tapa son of
Mongoose on your paw at stand-up or
movies that you poke ability to salmon
esto tiene pelea
[Music]